[Music]
you wake to the sound of crashing waves
swelling and breaking against the
breakwaters outside your home
they have a rhythm to them a rhythm
you've grown accustomed to
like a heartbeat
they build swell and crash
build swell and crash again and again
splashing at the foundations of your
home
this is normal of course
after all
you're a lighthouse keeper
the sun has not yet risen and it's cold
in every part of the lighthouse except
your quarters
your day begins as you throw on your
heaviest sweater your knit cap and the
gloves your aunt knit for you this
spring
this is how every day starts for you
trudging up the stairs in the dim
pre-dawn light you make your way to the
observation room and its grand wide
windows to take weather readings from
the equipment
your hands trace the old pitted iron
railings as you make your way up the
tight spiral staircase in the center of
the lighthouse tower
you're starting to memorize the way the
railings feel you can tell how far up
you are based on the pits and metal
because you do this every day
every day the same
you could do this with your eyes closed
why do you do it
wake up in darkness type on an old
laptop with cold numbed fingers tell the
weather office that the horizon is clear
or that there's good visibility or that
there's heavy fog rapidly decreasing
barometric pressure a big storm actually
wow that's a that's a huge storm if
you're being honest
you snap out of your reverie as the sun
crests over the horizon and new readings
come in
red sky morning sailor take warning
it's your job to keep the bright shining
lamp atop the lighthouse tower lit to
let the ships at sea know where the
ocean ends and the sharp rocks and reefs
of the coast begin
it's most important when the visibility
is bad and right now a fog is rolling in
in an hour's time it'll be thickest pea
soup out there
they won't be able to see a thing except
for the bright beacon of the lighthouse
itself that cuts through the fog like
nothing else can that's why you do it
people are counting on you to keep that
land lit
and you know what
you've got this
it's checklist time
in the supply room you check up on your
supplies you've got plenty of batteries
for your flashlight spare fuses for the
fuse box and crucially lots of snacks
you hurry down to the basement where
your diesel generator is it's humming
away the fuel tank is full you just
checked this is your ritual you do this
every 12 hours every single day
it's boring but there's also a kind of
comfort in it a comfort in the
consistency of a simple job done well
the generator keeps the light on and the
lamp at the top of the lighthouse and it
also powers the heater in your bedroom
so there's that too
you made yourself some breakfast and a
mug of hot cocoa the kind from a packet
with the raspberry flavoring and you sit
in your favorite chair in the
observation room just watching the storm
build
big gray clouds fat and heavy with rain
swell in the sky
the wind picks up
white caps start blossoming on the
crests of waves and those clouds start
moving in faster and faster blotting out
the already dim sunlight
you start to see those sideways
lightning strikes that grasp between
clouds anvil crawlers they call them
the sign of a really big storm
it begins to rain and you can just make
out the rumble of the approaching storm
you radio with some of the bigger
container ships within distance and urge
them to get to port as soon as possible
because the radar is telling you that
the really nasty weather is coming and
fast
the wind picks up and as the rain begins
to batter the lighthouse it starts to
get harder and harder to hear what
people are saying over the radio
back on the observation deck the sea
swells are getting bigger the winds
whipping them up into these big gray
blue mountains and now they're starting
to beat against the upper windows of the
lighthouse so we're talking at least 80
feet here huge geysers of sea spray
foaming up and splashing against the
walls
when you send your weather report into
central the satellite connection drops
out in the rain and you have to switch
to the low frequency radio transmission
the rain on the windows sounds like
hammer blows the waves and the thunder
are coming so fast and so loud now that
you have difficulty telling them apart
a prodigious bolt of lightning splits
the sky and shows you the armada of
clouds on approach for just a second
it's time to check on the lamp
it's an extremely bright light refracted
through this delicate enormous
multi-faceted lens that vastly increases
its output making it visible for many
miles at sea
the motor's going underneath the lamp
and it's rotating the whole thing very
slowly sending a searchlight beam out
into the gloomy dark
modern lighthouses use leds but this
definitely isn't a modern lighthouse
plus you've grown accustomed to the
rhythmic groaning of the motor
it almost hurts to look at it that's how
bright it is but you're glad it's there
as the waves beat against the walls as a
beacon in the darkening fog
winter brings the night on quickly and
it's growing dark
it's a good thing the light is on
at least you're not out in one of those
ships on the water
the light suddenly goes out and you are
plunged into darkness it was so bright
in the lamp room in fact that you feel
completely blind
the lamp didn't burn out the the power
is gone the motor that rotated the lamp
has stopped moving all you can hear now
is the terrible storm and the waves
you've got to see if the generator gave
out you grab for your sturdy flashlight
but a lightning bolt strikes the
lighthouse at the same moment
you're safe it must have caught the
lightning rod you notice that even the
roar of the storm sounds muffled and
distant due to the ringing in your ears
and it takes you a beat to realize
you've dropped the flashlight
down the stairs
which you will now have to traverse in
total darkness
the wind howls the waves batter the
lighthouse and yet a feeling of
confidence washes over you as soon as
your hand touches that pitted cold iron
railing
you know this building backwards and
forwards you know every inch of the
stairwell based on the feel of the
railing alone you make this climb many
times each day when the sun blazes and
when it's completely dark
every day the same you could do this
with your eyes closed
halfway down the stairs you stop off in
the supply room and root around in the
darkness until you find one of
everything a fuse for the fuse box extra
batteries for the flashlight just in
case and for you a bar of chocolate
because you'll need it
every item was exactly in the place you
knew it'd be
on the landing just outside the supply
room you find the flashlight dented sure
but it still works
now that you can see again you run down
to the generator to find that it's still
running but all the lights are out a
fuse must have broken you hit the
emergency stop on the generator turn off
the switch that connects it to the
lighthouse's power system knock open the
fuse box and there it is a blackened
busted fuse you don't know how it
happened but you've got a fresh fuse in
there and replaced before you even have
time to think about it
you close the fuse box you turn the
generator back on and you pull that
switch
and the lights are on again
up the stairs let's go
the lights along the stairwell light
your path and by the time you make it up
to the lamp you know what you'll see
before you even get there a beacon in
the darkness sweeping out into that
rain-streaked indigo night
you did it you were prepared for this
moment and you met him because you were
consistent and careful
that bard of chocolate tastes better
than anything you've eaten in years
because more than anything
you earned it
your radio crackles to life and the
grateful captain of a container ship
thanks you for keeping the light on
she can see it now
and she and her navigator are using it
to plot a course to shore
remember this moment and remember this
feeling
[Music]
you are a lantern in the inky black a
light for others to see by you can do
this because you have done this
and you'll keep going
you